pues supone que no haber clemencia para
alexéi navalni y era una esperanza que
aunque pequeña existía en algunos
ámbitos de la oposición entre otras
cosas por lo que había ocurrido en el
pasado lo cierto es que hasta la fecha
las autoridades descubría la justicia
rusa siempre habían evitado que alexéi
navalni un carismático líder de la
disidencia rusa pasase largas temporadas
en prisión tal vez por el miedo a que su
popularidad creciese pero esta vez no ha
habido marcha atrás y aleccionaban me
parece que va a tener que pasar dos años
y medio en una prisión que todavía no se
ha determinado puesto que sigue en un
centro de detención preventiva porque
tiene todavía un juicio pendiente del
cual tendrá que responder hoy por cierto